I'll tell you why it's fitting that I do
this interview um because I idolized
this dude I've been watching him from
when he came on the scene and um he just
blew us all away when I say us there's a
bunch of folks out there who think and
write and talk Etc And Then There are a
subset of us that also grow some
businesses and this guy came along from
a growing business's perspective so I
don't know look you've you've read this
stuff you know the bellus hacking
baseball card you know the wine guy you
know that right but let me tell you
something you could not find a smarter
more astute businessman um who has in
the modern era realized the tools that
one uses to grow a business so this
isn't about social media when you really
listen to him and talk to him it's just
about the way business is done today in
addition to that he he lives his brand
um look he is an egomaniac narcissist
fantastic
[Laughter]
guy who just kicks ass is the bottom
line so this is going to be a lot of fun
um and I'm I've been looking forward to
it for for quite a long time thank you
Keith all right with that in mind um the
way I want to try to divide this up is
into three parts the first part is a
short one to talk generally about
content and storytelling and to talk a
little bit about how one gets one
message out there in the aggregate but
what's really powerful about this book
by the way and you'll notice it's it's
just dog geared to death in back is the
way I mean in the way that we consume
media today he created a book which is
so weirdly interesting and antithetical
because this is an old media platform
and he created and he used it in a New
Media way you see story after Story and
everyone embedded in that is like a
little Hershey's Kiss of a gift of a
lesson to learn and so I'm flipping
through it and there's tons of stories I
don't want to lose the stories so what
we're going to do is we're going to
start generally about content then we're
going to go through each of the major
platforms that every one of you should
be understanding and using and I'm going
to throw out some stories he's going to
tell you some of those stories real time
right so hopefully all of that will
will'll drive you right to the back of
the room look this guy doesn't need your
money um but you I'll take it actually
that's true he will but he doesn't need
your money but he what we want to do is
he wants to change the way you live your
life and so go buy the damn book and
we'll get back to that all right from a
Content perspective generally um I mean
this book you know jab jab jab right
hook is really about give give give then
ask and that's why I love the guy so
much it really is about how to be of
service how do you serve in life and in
the social media World let me ask just
generally about the the jab jab jab
philosophy um and and relative to
telling stories on online are are there
any simple formulas associated with
telling a great story or as you point
out in this book the story is is really
tied to the platform and therefore it's
different but are there any Uber
Concepts that people should think about
first some level first you have to know
your story I talk a lot about I said
something yesterday during the book A
book signing that really stuck with me
and I don't say it often enough which is
if you're selling there's nothing I
can do for you right my purpose is is to
get you as much exposure and awareness
and attention as possible that's the
only thing I've ever tried to do for my
business myself and the businesses I'm
involved with but they're really just at
bats right they're just at bats to give
you another chance to
storytelling enough to convert on your
right hook and somebody buys your book
or your wine or hires your service or
buys your cell phone or whatever you
sell if that product is then not good
you're really in a troubled spot because
now you're hello now you're no longer in
a place where what you did was you
hunted well but what really matters is
farming right retention lifetime value
do you get a second sale this book is
going to do much better for me very
honestly than my others because it's
better and thus I've already seen the
word of mouth I mean I watched my Amazon
rank on thank you economy and now on jab
jab jab Ray hook very carefully and you
know thank you economy has the big lift
cuz I'm good at promoting and I did my
thing but it's slowly declined because I
wasn't getting virality to wake up this
morning and see that it's gotten more
sales it's going down means exactly what
I thought would happen yes I can show up
on all the podcasts and do all the right
things but it's been everybody's word of
mouth and listen and you said it and DJ
just walked in I mean people are coming
up to me and they like me I have this I
have a lot of friends that I've done a
good job in building relationships
people have found it very awkward to
tell me what they really feel this first
week has been really fun for me people
are coming up to me and saying you know
this is you know no disrespect but I
like this the most cuz you know all all
of them are like children you know I
think at the end of the day the first
thing is you have to know your story to
know your story I actually think every
you know this is the biggest thing I
hear all the time which is what is my
story the funny thing is I actually
don't think that that's the real
question I actually people I actually
think people know their story I think
people just don't have confidence in
what they actually sell you know I I
think salespeople are the best sales
people are the best people I've never
sold anything in my life that I haven't
believed in you know that's why my wine
show for ones that know that background
did so well because I panned so many of
the products that I sold which built so
much trust because I just was scared let
me me pause for a second on that because
I mean one of the things I've noticed
about you is that is is clearly as you
can tell his sense of passion right he
and I share that as friends and but
there are certain types of people who
who seek to find the passion in things
for themselves and you do I mean you
know while you say you know you haven't
sold anything you're not passionate
about you also really work to find the
passion and then in the same regard I'm
sure you've got to go to some of your
clients and help them find the passion
in their story take take a big company
like GE and our mutual friend Beth comto
um maybe maybe you can tell a little bit
about how do you get a big company that
actually wants to shift away from its
consumer I mean if anybody thinks of you
think of maybe you think of Light Bulbs
Etc but that's not even their business
right so how do you get a big company to
find passion in a story that they might
not even even find their passionate
they're different because of our mutual
friend and she's pretty special she is
the one client I have truly that from
the day they hired us let me do my thing
right I mean we anybody who follows G on
social networks we put out Ryan Gosling
Hey girl meme content for GE think about
that right I don't know if anybody
followed what we did two days ago or
yesterday I'm getting lost now with my
timing but we did three 3D printing day
on December 3rd it's toay the 4th or
5ifth thank you uh so two days ago on
Twitter and on a lot of networks we did
3D printing day I mean we came to them
with that idea because 3D printing is a
big meme it's going on they're
passionate about it we flipped and said
hey December 3rd let's make it a day you
can own it it took us 8 seconds for them
to say yes on this big initiative that a
lot of other companies will ponder you
know the way I've been able to get
companies all the rest of them to do
what I think are smart things that will
help them be more authentic real stories
things that you guys actually care about
very honestly has been Brute Force it's
been inappropriate conversations I'm not
joking it's the fact that I have so much
bravado was lucky enough that I was rich
before I started this business this this
is a real statement within the context
of the companies you're trying to coach
and kol this is what you're talking
about what you have to I have a company
called Vayner media we're a strategy and
creative shop and we produce all the
creative for social networks for major
Fortune 500 companies I'm talking Dove
and Mountain Dew GE Green Mountain cof
very very big Brands and the only reason
we're able to get them to do good work
against for of sheer luck of how this
started I don't need their money I'm so
obsessed with my own legacy this is true
I'm it's for it's far more interesting
he didn't say obsessed with his own self
he said his legacy which is which is the
gift he's trying to give so I wanted to
qualify that and I mean that I'm it's
more important for me to be associated
with work that changed the game and get
credit for it it's what I like what what
I like doing for a living is being
historically correct I'm not kidding so
here's the thing we're about to go
through a bunch of stuff that many of
you are going to want to bring into your
organizations many of you may not be in
Ultimate positions of authority to
execute some of these things can I jump
in right there please that's a the
single thing I'm most fascinated by I'm
aware that the advice that I give is Not
Practical to people that don't own their
own companies let me say one piece of
advice on that rant if you are
respectful with your feedback within
your organizations or your clients and
you don't waver and fold because you
just want to make the sale or not get
fired if you do it respectfully and put
it on the record this will pay humongous
dividends long term let me explain how
it happens by you fighting the board
your boss you know your boss's boss and
fighting I mean with a little bit of
passion but respectful because from a
practicality standpoint people don't
want to get fired but if you put it on
the record consistently and never waver
because you're just doing it to keep
your job or get the client to pay you
what will happen is in two three four
five years if you're so passionate and
you feel like you have a good enough of
track record of being historically
correct about these things what happens
is in two or three or four years when
you play out to be correct what happens
is you make so much more money because
what happens is the people that leave
that company that failed or get promoted
within it they remember that you were
right and you become a much more
important person within that
organization I have made far more money
by leaving money on the table up front
and then cashing in on it four to five
years later CU I was right about
e-commerce becoming a big deal in '94
and 95 because I was right about Google
search and sem being important because I
was right that you listen I started my
YouTube show nine months after YouTube
launched people made fun of me for it
they didn't think YouTube YouTube was a
fad if some of you remember right and so
and Twitter and I was right about Tumblr
and on and on and on and so the you know
I see where you're going with this
navigation let me I mean this book is
very much about how you can win online
no question let me use the same
methodology for a moment to interpret as
to how you can win uh in a high touch
world as well jab jab jab right hook
means um be generous be generous be
generous do do everything you can do to
make that boss of yours or that
influencer successful make them the
heroes as best as you can right and over
time you will earn the permission to
influence if you make other people
successful in life I mean this is what
we taught in Never Eat Alone it's all
about all great relationships give you
permission for influence but in order to
get great relationships nobody wants to
be your friend you've got to be deeply
generous so you bust your ass to be
generous over an extended period of time
and you will gain permission to put all
of his stuff into practice right hook is
bigger than Jabs on this book that is
all correct but I'm a little bit tired
SL frustrated slash passionate about
helping those people that are paying
forward and doing the right thing to
learn that there is an appropriate time
to throw the right hook that you have
you know the best people it comes
natural to them to give unfortunately
there's a upset of that that don't know
how to ask or are crippled to go for the
ask or are fearful to go for the ask and
without that ask people will take
advantage of just jabbing it's true you
know you know and that's okay by the way
I'll tell you why I can live this
philosophy because I actually have zero
expectation in return and that's a very
big variable to this whole thing if you
find yourself as a person who's often
disappointed by others this may not be
your philosophy this might not be the
right Philosophy for you what really
allows me to play this game is the fact
that if I don't land the right hook I'm
actually not upset with that person
organization or situation let me let me
try that's not for everybody let me try
to understand make sure we got it right
giving without keeping score which is
the words that that I would typically
use um doesn't mean to be a doormat all
right so giving without keeping scored
means that's the approach the mindset
that you walk into a relationship or you
walk into giving however not asking and
or letting people take without giving
back is something that at some point you
have to walk away from so you've got to
put the ask out right in order for you
to be honored with the giving that you
have but here's the key and this is my
suggestion abandon the sense of
resentment or abandon the sense of a
balance sheet just walk away and and
some of you who are staying there
forever and just getting walked on is
not the answer either the other thing
that I would say is try to make as many
of your Jabs not be silent just to that
relationship let them be a little bit
more known because the person that you
might be trying to land the right hook
on you might not be able to land on but
other people that have seen it seen the
Jabs might value that and give you
opportunities elsewhere so if you can
make them a little bit more transparent
and out there there's a little more
value with that as well you know what I
want to do is and I'll come back to some
of these some of these more General
topics later but there's such a richness
in the way this book is organized by
very small vignettes and case studies
it's just fun to be leafing through and
grabbing them the pictures grab you by
the way and they should do because
they're supposed to grab you in a
crowded media world right so if this
book it doesn't grab you as you open it
up and leave through it it would have it
would have been at fault but it isn't it
works so what I want to do is I want to
go by by platform one of the things that
really hit me and look I when I wrote
never read alone Facebook didn't even
exist um so we're rewriting Never Eat
Alone for launch next year so it's going
to be Never Eat Alone 2.0 on the social
media World um the the and I don't and I
am not an expert here so I'm like a
in this space and I that's
probably Politically Incorrect I'm sorry
I'm not a tall person um whatever it is
the the the point that I want to make is
here the big aha for me was the way you
tell your story is going to be different
per platform so let's March through the
platforms okay let's I want to jump in
if you don't
mind I believe that 95% of the people
that are using social networks to to
drive any kind of business or life
result are using Facebook and Twitter
specifically because that's where the
most volume is as distribution networks
we're treating Facebook and Twitter as a
whole as email newsletters we're just
blasting we're we're putting out a tweet
that has a link to something else
instead of realizing that these
platforms are places to tell stories
within natively you have to tell your
story within the 3 seconds that
somebody's going through their phone on
Twitter and then because you've
successfully told your story there that
becomes the gateway to everything else
when you're just putting out a tweet
saying hey I wrote an article about
oranges and it's a link you're not doing
any value for anybody within that
platform putting a picture within
Twitter within the size of a Twitter
card that has a orange and maybe a quote
from the article becomes a much more
consumable piece so you need to think
almost like yeah you made a great movie
but if you don't make a great preview to
that movie you you may not sell as many
tickets to that movie so let's but let's
split them down let's split down
Facebook to Twitter cuz even within
those two I until I read the book I
didn't realize some of that distinction
so if you're talking about Facebook one
of the things I learned here is you're
really talking about engagement a
wonderful story talk about Air Canada I
love that one and then by the way the
picture was so so clear in here but talk
about Air Canada yeah so with Air Canada
that was the the woman right who was a I
did I did 447 case studies to get this
70 four 9 months ago so I'm a little bit
wonky on this but that this was the
woman that worked there for a drillion
years yeah and she just passed away and
it was they did a great job they did a
great job they they kind of talked about
a woman who was a flight attendant and
worked there forever and or I'm not sure
if she was a fllying t but she was there
from the beginning or or she flew with
them the whole time help me he no this
is this is a woman what's that she was
she was the very first you want me to
I'm going to tell the story all
right I read the book I read the book in
the last 24 hours so but by the way I
totally get this if you ask me some
people will come to me and say I love
you know that 47 what I love you did I'm
like f what are you talking
about right so I mean here here was the
lesson here was a story that was so
powerful um the the oldest flight
attendant just passed away right for Air
Canada and what a possible moving
opportunity but the text Heavy
obituary the the the the lack of a
picture right just totally fell flat in
terms of the opportunity that they had
what they did on Facebook what all of
you do which is they had a longer form
article about it so they put the link in
Facebook and as you know if you manage
your Facebook pages or ever work with it
if you put a link within your Facebook
fan page Facebook does a nice job and
populates a picture right from the
article and that's all they did and by
the way that's what 98% of people do
because Facebook does the work for you
and we're all worried about our time see
with this really gets to is that we're
all so worried about WID then we're not
realizing all the action is in depth and
so that the extra 40 minutes that it
would have taken to do a nice picture
that would have actually worked on
Facebook well and and look what Gary did
so Gary and his team they went ahead and
they actually redid the ad for them in
the book going from one page to the
other it was just so obvious and then I
sit there and get embarrassed for myself
because I realize that how many
opportunities that have I Tak 3 minutes
instead of 30 seconds right I could have
transformed the message in the story and
you're talking about for someone like
you know if you have a Fage of 50,000 or
5 million or whatever range you are even
if you have if you're a solopreneur here
and you have a fan page of a hundred
people that's going to allow you to
reach 80 people of your 100 instead of
32 and that's just all that matters
right it's it's getting more CH if
you're going to take the effort to try
to
storytellers right now we're in a very
funny spot we're five to six years in so
it's mature enough now that people are
actually putting effort and money into
it so now we start getting into the real
questions of Roi is this really worth it
and what's really happening is these
platforms are so different than anything
that we've ever come from that I see
here's what I see I see everybody
starting to become cynical about a lot
of these platforms when what I see is
the tools not broken the mechanics are
broken right that you know the ROI of a
piano for Keith and I is zero the ROI of
books for us has been phenomenal the ROI
of a piano for Elton John and Billy Joel
was quite a bit so the ROI is predicated
on how you use the tool you know in
theory a basketball is broken to me as a
money-making proposition it wasn't for
LeBron right so social networks work but
we are coming off this is the single
most important point that I did not make
in the book we are coming from a digital
world where things were actually quite
scalable and automated banner ads search
engine optimization email marketing
these things actually were quite
automated social ironically is very
heavy human very heavy touch very
long-term we came from
sprinting and we're going to a marathon
and most of us aren't trained for this
Marathon I'm going to come back in look
there's so many tips in here I want to
keep coming bringing him back to the
stories which I tell for him um so the
Kat the Katy Perry story was a great one
I mean here you are and you you look
here and there's there's this wonderful
picture of Katy Perry with a UNICEF
t-shirt right she's jumping rope with
some little girls and then they just
drowned you with facts right as
opposed to his suggestion on how to how
to provoke somebody into wanting to know
more particularly a fan base of kater
Perry wanting to know more about where
she's spending her time so what you
don't give in that case so in the other
case it was really understanding how to
how to emotionalize using a picture and
using the right headline how to
emotionalize your story and in the next
story it was how to provoke and not give
too much that it ended up being boring
and you weren't interested anymore from
the headline did understand that he
really makes that distinction the thing
is is when you're go here's how we're
consuming social
networks you have a third of a second to
grab somebody's attention when you write
a ton of copy on your Facebook post
people tune out because the psychology
of why they're there is to using your
term eat popcorn not a seven course meal
and so people are trying to apply seven
course meals into a medium where you're
supposed to snack on content we need to
be selling gateway drugs on these
platforms not the real deal that's a
great one and so now we're moving on
from from Facebook on onto Twitter right
so by the way what he what he just said
is obviously a tweetable moment I'm
hoping all of you will I would assume
that this is one of the few speeches
where you're allowed to have your your
cell phones out all right and and
stupidly by the way I forgot mine at
home this morning I had to send my
driver back to get it and literally on
the way down I was dialing in my quotes
to the head of social media for our
company I'm like get on the computer I'm
going to be calling you with my it's a
funny thing to rip on I would literally
Rather somebody roll up on me stab me
with a knife and steal my wallet then
lose my
phone like that's how how valuable the
phone has become right I mean how many
people here real quick by show of hands
for fun how many people here literally
in every 24-hour window including when
you're sleeping are always within Arm's
Reach of their telephone look at
that how many of you will develop some
form of brain cancer within 23 25 years
by the way that is by the way that
literally is the number one thing I'm
scared of you know I I'm not even joking
every day literally once a week I'm like
these are our cigarettes
right you know how we sit now and make
fun of everybody for cigarettes your
next tweet are our
cigarettes I really I I really think
that these are our cigarettes I have a
bad feeling about all this all right
well
sorry just just to bring the mood all
the way down you're all
dying the gateway drug the gateway drug
all right so let's move on to Twitter
for a second and now I I found this
interesting I mean he he he and by the
way we're going to do a Q&A and
periodically I'm going to actually why
the hell go ah yeah you talked about the
ROI of a social platform investment
could you talk more about it because uh
every event I go to uh the major concern
is how much money do I put what am I
getting out of it I was talking to this
uh VP at NBC Universal and I own a
creative agency so we do a lot of
analytics so he's like if you can solve
this problem I'll give you a deal so I
just wanted to get you you know so here
here's the first question I ask and I
deal with all those same clients right I
asked as them to show me the ROI of what
they're spending their money on when
they're not doing this I mean that's
where this conversation becomes very
valuable right because unless you were a
direct to Consumer DTR direct
salesperson and the reason we wanted to
work with Green Mountain Coffee and the
NFL even though those were projects not
what I normally do is I had a way to
quantify sales right and so even though
you know when you talk to NBC Universal
or you know I have TV clients and the
kpi is neelon rating I mean you have to
really get concerned about that because
I don't believe in neelon ratings to
begin with you've got 2,800 boxes
representing 300 million people and like
you know I mean it's ludicrous I mean
every one of my most analytical every
kid coming out of MIT the hardest core
data people in the world today that you
know the real Whiz Kids of the Next
Generation they laugh because they
didn't grow up with neelon or iri or or
they laugh at the quantifiable evidence
of what success is in Corporate America
today literally to the point where I'm
like am I I should write a book called
The Dark Ages which is the last 80 years
of marketing where people believe I mean
outdoor media is a multi-billion dollar
industry that's predicated on men going
on top of buildings snapping how many
cars drove by and wrode a math amplifier
to justify the ROI of billboards in a
world where every person here if they're
not driving is looking at their cell
phone and are missing that impression so
so the first way I do it is like listen
I go very gunsblazing to that question I
say great show me every Roi that you've
accepted because that's the real game
unless you quantifiably take the link to
so some of you if you really pay
attention might have seen IBM's last
report this week that only 1% of black
Friday's sales came from social media
and everybody's like meanwhile they
tested 17 sites right it's the they all
17 of those companies suck at social
media because they're using the jet
they're throwing right hook right hook
right hook right hook right hook right
hook right hook of course it's not going
to convert and number two it's all based
on last attribution if you're going to
go with last attribution well then we
can't talk about marketing at all
there's no reason to do any marketing so
I get very serious about that that's
number one number two the way I've been
able to do it was I I don't know if any
of you saw this I was very fortunate I
had a very major profile in the New York
Times 3 weeks ago and I got double
fortunate for some reason my client
mandes decided to disclose stuff that I
would have never disclosed if I were
them because we're starting to see real
results and nobody thinks there's Real
Results and I think that's a competitive
Advantage for the first couple years but
they disclosed that on Nila Wafers the
nil crackers that we did the work and
they have a 9% increase on business this
year like the real kpi the real Roi not
more Impressions not more good feelings
9% increase in sales for a brand that
hasn't grown in 10 years okay and here's
where it gets interesting we stumbled
into it we got
$600,000 of their $900,000 marketing
budget for the year they don't support
the brand $900,000 for a brand of that
size is ludicrous they don't support it
the Le 300,000 went to us when something
broke so what ended up happening was we
had all $900,000 of the budget for the
brand every dollar the brand spent that
year we spent on making creative on
Facebook Pinterest and at the end of the
year 9% growth of sales period no debate
so now ironically I'm actually going
through Unilever and Pepsi and all my
clients and asking them for small Brands
not big Brands where they'll give us all
the money because the easiest way for me
to prove the ROI now is if you spend all
your money with me you're either going
to grow or not and it's a it's a very
good way so one of the things you may
want to do is silo something where they
only spend money on a thing because then
it becomes net net that year that's the
ROI if there's any question of the ROI
look at the guy to my left right I mean
this was a a family wine business
proprietor and look where he is today
and do you think that anything other
than social media and his own tenacity
of course but he used these tools and
here you are here's an example a man who
who his agency's now 300 people I I
spent a lot of money on TV print radio
television Billboards to build up wine
library.com and then with Wine Library
TV realized this Twitter Facebook thing
let me just you know I'm always GNA I'm
the if I if I was on the Christopher
Columbus Crew I would have been the guy
in that crew when we landed in America
that they said look at this weird Bush
and that fruit I'm like I'll eat it you
know knowing that I would die or or it
would be good that's in my DNA I
actually am baffled by people asking me
questions like but what's the risk risk
of doing Snapchat and Pinterest to me
it's always my brain only works in one
way I'm like the risk of not doing it is
far greater than the risk of doing it
and until people realize that they're
going to struggle obviously this is a
guy who believes P he's like the Hair
Club for Men like he's also a client so
um over there to the left it's true it
really is
true I um I work with independent
filmmakers by the way I have a film
coming out
on on uh brain cancer associated with
cell
phones but uh in sort of carrying on is
it are we finished we are okay IGN knew
it IGN knew it just uh just don't keep
it on your body as long as it's AR arms
distance away you're good but uh great
the the question is is when you talk
about Nilla wafers and you the amount of
testicular cancer in this room right now
get it out of your
pocket right is uh you talk about sort
of the conversion you increase sales 9%
and was there something in particular
other than cuz so much about uh
converting right is not just exposure
but it's creating a relationship and
sort of a desires to increase you know
to actually get somebody to convert that
is that's jabbing that's actually
providing value and then actually asking
for the sale like if I'm if I'm
marketing a film I'm spending nine as
you're making the film I'm storytelling
I'm making animated gifts every day on
Tumblr around your film the stuff that
you may even edit out and I'm
storytelling on these platforms daily
just giving out stuff I'm doing a spree
cast or Ustream or a Google Hangout with
the actors or doctors or whoever you
have in film months before the film
comes out you know how to sell a book
sell it for nine months before it comes
out and then it actually sells not okay
my book's out now it's time to sell
game's over you don't have enough time
so same thing with a film for as long as
you're F the future of film marketing is
as you're filming it you're storytelling
on these platforms and then when the the
film comes out you've actually built a
community and you come out and say buy
the tickets like the one thing I really
preach in this book is not being half
pregnant with your ask you know
literally my posts right now on social
networks are buy my book link direct
right hook I feel that I've jabbed
enough to have the permission to say
that and so to me you know thinking
about your world it's about making these
pieces of content day in and day out you
know it's funny that used the movie
preview you take it to the extreme I
mean you know depending on who you want
to see this things like Snapchat I'm
jumping a little bit here but I want
people to understand right now Nate are
you done yet did you send it so
Snapchat I think is seriously the most
interesting marketing platform right now
most people reading headlines think it's
a bunch of kids saying sending naked
selfies to each other ludicrous here's
probably but still here's the real
action you know what Snapchat does it it
fixes the one thing that actually
matters attention because the picture
comes to you and you know that you can
only hold it down for 10 seconds and
then it disappears you're actually
paying attention for those 10 seconds so
right now I just took a snap before we
went out here and I sent out uh you know
the snap and the reason Nate hasn't I
asked him if he sent it is Snapchat's so
new that you can't send a snap to
everybody so Nate how long did it take
you 15 minutes so literally for 15
minutes poor Nate has been hitting every
person that follows me on Snapchat to
send the snap to so it's ludicrous this
product so new that it doesn't even make
it easy to do this you know 15 minutes
we hit everybody and then it sends out
but people are actually going to pay
attention to it and then they're going
to Tweet which is what I asked them to
do and I've been able to make things
trend on Twitter for the first time in
four years because I've asked people to
use a hashtag from snap because even
though I only have 5,000 people there
4,000 are actually going to open it and
pay attention to it Which is far greater
than the million people that follow me
on Twitter when I push something out
with all the noise that's on Twitter
maybe 480 will see it this time 720 the
next time it's not about Top Line it's
about depth that sounds exhausting I I
mean I recognize my challenge as a as an
entrepreneur myself everything great is
exhausting is how much time should these
folks be spending or there or waiting
until they fit fix their stuff waiting
until it's clearer like how much time
you you make a livelihood all this hair
club forment thing I'll steal and give
you credit to build your brand I mean I
I eat I say I eat my own dog food you
know the reason I'm good at this stuff
is because I do it first when vine came
out I have a at that point my company's
probably 180 people of the best
marketing you know all that stuff I have
great people Vine comes out in late
January three two three weeks after Vine
comes out I am by far the expert on Vine
in my organization you know why comto
was Bragg on that day that here we are
General Electric not P not perceived as
a you know avanguard social media
company but it is um had the very first
video out there on Vine because of you
and so the other interesting part is
here's how I became the leader within my
organization on Vine every night of the
first three weeks of February from 11:00
p.m. to 3: in the morning I played with
Vine I used it I made videos I watched
whatever everybody else was doing I paid
attention to the nuances I used it you
know the amount of people that have have
debates about the ROI of these things I
sit in a room and they're like I'm like
listen Instagram is the single most
important Social Network right now this
is the advice I'm giving to my staff now
it's a little bit difficult for internet
marketers because it's purely a print
play you can't link out of Instagram so
it's difficult talk about justifying the
ROI it's print it's print it's like
running an ad in Vogue or Sports
Illustrated that's all it is is you
can't do anything else with it it stays
within the confines but the amount of
feedback that I get from clients or
other experts or taste makers or people
that have points of view on Instagram's
Roi and then I ask the funny question
which is do you use
it and half of them don't even have an
Instagram account but surely have a big
opinion about it and to me that's what
the rubber hits the road definitely
worth the billion Facebook paid for it I
said it at the time
you know I predicted that Facebook would
buy Instagram on a show that I was doing
called The Daily that old app and so CNN
had me on the day it happened because I
predicted it and I thought they stole it
you go watch the comments that day on
Twitter I'm an idiot I'm an idiot that
was such a a billion dollar I mean think
about how you felt when you heard a
billion dollars for Instagram right it
was only 551 days old right but I knew
that they needed to control the next
generation of photo users which is why I
believed in it that is a they they stole
Instagram stole it so how artist how do
you be artistic on I mean Instagram is a
unique artistic sensibility I'm not
great at it that's a whole another thing
right I use everything but there's
certain things you guys know I'm great
at Twitter because it's basically
conversational and I'm good with people
you know I'm good at video which is why
YouTube worked for me but Instagram I
grew up in a family there's six pictures
of me tell them what kind of an ethic it
is and some of them might not even know
how artistic it is and what you need to
do there I will in a second but this is
even funnier
from the ages of 6 to 16 I think there's
six pictures of me ever my family did
not grow up taking pictures in the
Soviet Union where my family's from you
didn't take pictures and the ones that
were taken I have 700 pictures of the
old country and my family not one person
smiling in a picture it was a very
depressing place anyway you know it can
be a lot of things Instagram is Artistic
for the reason it works is a lot of
people like taking photos photos are a
very big part of our culture you can go
with a lot of things on Instagram
Instagram one because it makes you
better at taking pictures you know you
start adding filters your picture looks
a little bit better Instagram's a
utility that became a network it made
you better at something that we cared
about the bottom line if you're going to
take a picture on Instagram instead of
going here hold it down there and take
it up the nostril something just it's
got to be interesting you've got to play
with your and that's one of the things
the book did for me it made me realize
that every time I use a different social
media platform I've got to adapt to it
and I want to go to Twitter for a second
um I'm just going to jump in real quick
because there's a point I really want to
make the reason Instagram won is the
same reason I think this book's going to
win for me Instagram made you better at
taking photos this is the first time I
wrote a book to try to make you better
at this stuff instead of tell you why
it's important and I can tell you right
now that if you reverse engineer that
listen when I wrote this book I read
every negative review of my last two
books on Amazon twice and the only
things that happened were he tells you
why he's spieling his POV it's a talker
and I'm like okay I respect that and so
knowing that I've built my businesses by
doing I F that's why I went here and I
can tell you right now that if you take
a step back and whatever you do for a
living if you can make your users
whether you're B2B or B Toc if you can
make them better you will win we are
going into a very major place of utility
right now people are valuing utility
very heavily because time has become the
asset time has exploded in value because
we live in a 24/7 world now we used to
all remember when we used to be able to
luckily there's not that many kids in
the crowd remember when we used to be
able to go home and your other part of
your life went on now because of cell
phones I mean you send me an email at
9:30 my clients or my friends or my
associates or my co-workers they sent me
an email at 9:30 p.m. they expect the
response there's a different expectation
so in a 24/7 World which is is what we
now play in time is the asset that we
value more than anything the lady in the
white you had a question earlier
yeah thank you um you sort of disdain
the folks who are not actually using the
social media they're talking about their
Roi on what if your decision makers or
your consumers aren't make aren't using
that social media then you shouldn't be
there but my belief is that that is not
true I do not believe there's that we
between Facebook from an from an age
standpoint and Linkedin from a B2B
standpoint I do not believe that you
know outside of here's a good one I
helped a nursing home as a because it
was a friend of a friend not for Vayner
media not for me not for a case study
just a couple pieces of advice they're
like listen our clients are 80 to you
know 90 years old right I'm like they're
not they're kids are your actual client
there's plenty of 40 50 and 60 year olds
on Facebook and when they started making
content for them they started converting
and so here's another one if you look at
the Dynamics here's why I like Snapchat
Vine and Instagram to sell to
40-Year-Old women even though they're
not there if you look at the data right
now 40 to 50 year old women that have
daughters that are between the age of 8
and 16 the 8 to 16-year-old is affecting
their mother's buying habits so much
more than 10 or 20 years ago where it
was the other way around because we're
living through the youthification of our
society if you look at the habits the
way they dress the way they act what
they do day in and day out the average
45-year-old woman today is acting more
similar to a 27y old woman only 20 years
ago that if you sit right now men and
female and you think about what your
parent looked like when they were your
age right this minute you know I mean
people thought they were done only two
or three generations ago at 50 67 right
now we we're so lucky we're living
longer we're taking better care of
ourselves and we're living through this
massive youthification
right that you know the cougar movement
that was so fun to make jokes about is a
very real thing and so I we listen we
have Dove we have other brands we're
marketing to 15-year-old girls to make
their moms buy something because if
their daughter thinks it's cool their
mom will buy it and so I don't know what
you do
so Legal Services is a great example of
being in the content business so let me
explain where I'll go with you on this
Legal
Services I'm going to give you an
example of Guinness beer Guinness beer
had a problem about 60 years ago they
had Pub sales decline in the UK for the
first time ever and they're like what
are we going to do they went and did old
school market research and surveyed
people in bars and they found out the
two biggest things that people talked
about were soccer and trivia so so they
created the Guinness Book of World
Records so I don't know how many of you
know that I didn't know this until even
a year ago but I'm just curious how many
people had no idea that Guinness beer
started Guinness Book of World
Records so what they did was they
started a media company to solve their
problem I would tell you in legal
services that if you're if you're
focused on a certain genre that in this
book and I spend a little time on it
it's a whole another book and a genre I
believe I'm going to make a pretty big
statement that I want everybody wrap
their head around I believe every person
in this room right now and the
organizations that you're involved in
whether business-wise NGO whatever you
do every one of you and it are in the
media business I now believe that you're
in the media business comma Legal
Services I'm in the media business comma
agency comma wine it's why I started my
wine show so I actually think what you
need to seriously consider in this world
is to become a media company meaning put
out content long form around not
necessarily legal but the kind of things
that interest the people that you're
trying to court and then in a
buzzfeed.com way where you have no ads
but every fifth post is a is a native ad
think of it as advertorial 2.0 think
about you this is very Rogue so I know
it's going to be tough to digest but I
want to pitch you something think about
you starting a golf website right
literally covering golf competing
against Golf Digest and that every th
post was promoting your business I
actually believe that that is going to
be a blueprint of people doing business
that they're going to start creating
media and content around the interest of
the Target that they're trying to
recruit for their business over here to
the left question and I know it's left
feel but I can see you know it's it's
it's listen I I just want to stick on
this because it's such a big point and I
think it's the next decade the thought
that we have to be in the media business
because the cost of Entry is zero and
not truly zero but in comparison to
starting Golf Digest or the golf Network
by putting a golf daily.com on WordPress
and then producing micro content to
drive traffic the cost of Entry is so
low thus getting those us so it gets
it's a very interesting thing I've been
testing it it's remarkable we're
launching our first ever we have a
cracker and we're launching the leading
cheese review site of the internet in
March and we're going to be by building
that it's going to be a gateway to the
Cracker and we don't necessarily want
them to match the cracker and the cheese
it's just that we want to elevate the
brand Equity of the cracker and by doing
it with high-end cheese it will do that
for us but that's the kind of stuff and
that's owning the media instead of
buying banner ads on the media he
mentioned something in passing that the
book does well which is talks about not
only the big content but the micro
content how important that is that's the
jab jab jab the ability to just be out
there is a great let you find it
yourself the great uh Oreo tweet for the
Super Bowl uh blackout which is
something you should look for in the
book y yeah so you talk about depth
instead of width but obviously with so
many networks there is width the human
capital obviously is harder to scale
than automating email marketing
impossibly difficult if you get a you
know you get a new client Dove or
whatever how many people are on that
account like how many hours per week
just enormous 11 you know times 50 you
know 600 hours a week I mean real time
now Dove right we're not all dove I mean
and all and by the way the time so
you're right the time you have to put in
the time but let me just make it clear
this is like exercise you're going to
get the results of the time you put in I
know what it takes to get like chest
muscles and pecs and muscle I don't have
them because I haven't put in a time so
you don't have to do this but the only
way to get results in this is to
actually do it now the good thing is
when you're building a personal brand
like Keith and I have and other people
have it really sucks because you
actually have to do it when you're a
logo you can build a team have interns
have other people I mean retailers drive
me crazy they're like we don't have the
bandwidth I'm like meanwhile you have
7,000 employees in your storees doing
nothing at the register for 4,000 hours
a week if you just gave them a computer
to do something I mean the what I call
sawdust right everybody tells me we have
no budget I'm like you have 29,000
employees I'm like we can fine
budget right so you know I I think it
the number one thing I would say the
number one thing I would say if you're a
solopreneur or small business is audit
what you're doing literally look at
every dollar and every hour that you
spend I promise you if you cut the
bottom
10% of what I call Dumb money that
you've spent because you've always spent
it you always went to that trade show
every year so you go again but it
doesn't bring you the value that it did
15 years ago you always do this thing
that thing the next thing anyway if you
cut the bottom 10% of what you do and
you take that money and time and you
produce content and bring value to the
actual end user or potential end user of
your business you will get better Roi
Gary asked me a question in the in the
back how much time do you spend
promoting yourself versus promoting froi
Greenlight and I said that's a great
question because I think there are many
people in this room that have similar
questions relative to the personality of
an individual themselves versus their
business on social media and where you
go back and forth um one big company I
know it's a u u an insurance firm whose
CEO is notorious for being an incredibly
advid uh Tweeter and as a result he
actually says a lot of really dumb
yeah exactly and his organization is
constantly saying take that phone back
no not in a board meeting because you're
going to say stuff you shouldn't right
take that phone back so that's one end
of the extreme on the other end of the
extreme you know an organization like
ours where we're struggling and nobody
gives a dam about frozy Greenlight but
the personality of Keith frozy is a
little bit more interesting do you have
any comments on that relative to
individuals many who may be smaller
entrepreneurs looking at that balance
it's about storytelling what value
proposition farazi Greenlight though has
enormous depth of information and the
fact that farazi Greenlight does not put
out an infographic every week of some
information of lightweight content that
can go quite viral especially if you
think about the female demo on Pinterest
Pinterest infographics is just gold and
so if you actually make the infographic
with the Pinterest female demo in mind
you can create great results and so in a
world of you know listen I'm six of my
last 11 six of my last 10 uh Investments
are in female entrepreneurs right seven
of the 11 leaders in my company are
female right we're living through an
incredible time where EQ is becoming
more valuable than IQ which just by
generalization lends itself to going
towards the female side luckily I'm
quite girly so I'm good
but you know I think you could put out
tremendous something tells me this
audience wouldn't necessarily concur
that the personal they're in front of
them is particular if they dug deep
they'd realize I am and so what I think
what I think is interesting is you could
crush putting out infographics and so
it's about storytelling what you can
actually bring to the table there's
uniquely things that you can do there's
uniquely things that I can do but
there's definitely unique things that
our organizations can do I mean listen I
could have not wrote jab jab jab right
without Vayner media because I did so
much of this work at scale and I had a
team that helped me go through thousands
of case studies to get down to 500 which
then I worked out it just wouldn't have
happened right and that's why it's
deeper because it's not just me anymore
with my intuition it's actually granular
with the work that's where you have a
shot the lady at the top
yes your way down shout if you want to
just shout it out we'll repeat it I I
can kill the White Noise here and so
that that's what it's about it's about
figuring out what you do best as an
organization and then storytelling that
in the proper channels contextually to
the channels so an infographic works but
then you could also do an animated gift
with a quote from you that lends itself
to a
report um I have an entry in the global
startup battle uh and I'm trying to get
votes without buying them I need a
thousand in the next two days is there
anything I can
do so this comes back to how do you sell
a book you do it for9 months before it
comes out we had a week yeah but you
didn't really have a week you've had
your whole life and so you know to me to
me the answer is social yes but not
social media I would tell you to look at
things like outbrain where you can buy
distribu I mean if you are you talking
about spending money no no no we can't
you can't you're not allowed to you know
not you know not from a I don't know in
a week nothing nothing I talk about
could do that well that's not true you
you pick your 30 actual friends so in
the same regard you might not have built
the following but hopefully you've built
the network the relationships so go call
and lean on heavily a group of
individuals that have some extension
that was the first thing you did you
already did that of course if like any
contest that that that that's why I said
nothing because I just know without even
asking I knew that was her first move
did you actually do the ask it's there's
nothing more frustrating to me when you
do this broadcast email to all your
network and you say will you help me and
nobody does because they don't know that
you are and you're not on the other hand
you actually pick up the phone you call
each of them work through the process of
what they need to do and then ask them
if they wouldn't mind reporting what
they did you might actually get some
better results yeah I did that for about
10 people but I could keep going that's
the only thing you got go to at this
stage look for both of this whether it's
personal relationships in the real world
or whether it's what you're building as
a following in fany it's build it before
you need it over here to the and I'm
going to just jump on that a little bit
really go for the right hook like of
those 10 people go look I'm listen I did
this for my new book I have so many
friends and contemporaries and
acquaintances that write books or have
kickstarters and they and they blast an
email and I don't feel personal with
that I'm like they sent it to everybody
so I literally emailed one by one talk
about it sounds hard the email was
contextual hey how's Sally hey saw you
at the Padre's game I mean work like 11
minutes per one email or four minutes
per and they converted and then I got
real gangster because I'm so obsessed
with this book I'm going back now being
like hey Carl you didn't buy or blog or
talk about my book and then I come back
two weeks later and be like
Carl so of those 10 of those 10 people
did four of them do it did seven of them
do it did all 10 and if all 10 didn't go
back to those two and be like I wasn't
joking this is my this is one of my asks
that I'm going to have in my life that's
that's the that's the jab jab jab ask
and you really are allowed to do that
over here um my question is about sort
of The Sensational
emotional content that works so well but
how do you leverage that and still be
genuine and still you mean hyper bable
content well I mean Air Canada you know
that's somebody's life that's a woman
that's a female you think they exposed
her you know certainly brands do right I
mean there's times where you see things
and you're you're just like man what is
that how do how and it makes you feel
weird you know what the worst is for
everybody that follows us we'll donate a
dollar to the Haiti Relief Fund I want
to kill people I'm like you're a billion
company just give money to the relief
fund you're taking a disaster to try to
get more followers you piece of
totally so so my
yeah hate that so you know I guess my
question is and I'm not doing a good job
asking this question but how do how do
you use that in the right way how by
doing it the right way genuinely you
know like when you retweet I picked on
holiday in in this book that's a case
study I
remember for
retweeting like every tweet is a retweet
of somebody saying they had a good time
at holiday in you know what that's
called
bragging no your other followers don't
want you to just talk about how great
you are the funny thing is and again I
truly believe the reason that I over
indexed on social networks is because I
think social networks actually look a
whole lot like becoming rich when you
become rich and famous you don't change
you just become the extreme version of
what you are I get so much credit for
being a nice guy last night I had a book
party and I stood in one spot for 4 and
a half hours and just took pictures and
answered people's questions and just
blogs and articles and tweets of how
great of a guy I am I'm like that's
common courtesy I'm so lucky that people
want to take a picture with me so I
think social networks are just
accelerating and exposing and extremal
liing who we actually are so how do you
actually do it by doing it the right way
by actually acting human everybody
thinks on Twitter to win you've got got
to be funny or witty so you get retweets
how about being nice or listening or
bringing value I mean there's a lot of
attractive variables I I tell people all
the time and my clients I'm like the way
to win on social networks is the same
way that ugly dudes get beautiful women
right you have to have other attributes
you're not good-looking you know you're
you're a brand right you're a brand
nobody wants to hear from you oil
company so how do you win say do good
things be funny be you know be be I I I
did a blog post about sending flowers on
July 12th I'm obsessed with this notion
if I got if I bought flowers for my wife
on Valentine's Day I would get some sort
of value proposition meaning not like
the hahhaa value proposition but meaning
I get credit for doing the right thing
it feels nice if I buy her flowers on
July 12th out of nowhere the value of
that same exact action is 8,000 times
more valuable right those are the things
we have to do we have to bring value in
a lot of different ways so the answer
your question is quite basic it's how do
you do it you just do it the way you
would do it in real life what brings
value and that's why I think we've had a
lot of success we're doing we're for I'm
forcing these Brands to act human how do
do really quick on Twitter for a second
you're so you're such so Savant there
hashtags um can you give some advice on
how people should be using them
everybody wants their hashtag to Trend
let me let me let let me save you a lot
of time your hashtag is not going to
Trend unless you're a 15-year-old rapper
your #is not going to Trend okay so what
I say with hashtags is look at the
hashtags that are trending at that
moment and try to figure out how to say
what you wanted to say by using one of
them right that that is a huge secret
that I've talked about in this book that
I've already seen people use and are
getting so much but you have to be a
creative writer right if you want to
sell your law service and you see all
these funny slang things trending if
it's how do you make cyber monday fit
your thing you know you know for me you
know we did it for Wine Library a crush
it said take a second from stop clicking
on Cyber Monday and drink a penio killed
you know we we wanted to talk about
penio but we used what was trending at
that moment right and there's always
things trending like my first kiss how
do you make that work for what you're
selling having the chops to be creative
enough to come up with copy that lets
you sell what you're selling or bring
value to people while using thing that's
trending that's not exactly what you're
doing is a real skill it's like breaking
news versus is making a long form movie
right I tell all my creatives in my
organization I tell them you're in the
breaking news business at oleby and
widen and Kenn and all these other
places you guys came from you were in
the film making business it was very
romantic you were creative off the
pre-existing hashtag you're now in the
president's been shot how are you going
to go on the air here here's where we're
going to go we're going to left over
there lady here sorry bud you've already
had one question on the guy up there
Gary so I have been a chef uh an event
manager for more than two days decades
and the philosophy has been you're only
as good as your last event you're only
as good as your last meal you have been
the seminal figure in deconstructing
that so thank you um now in the social
media realm can you speak to that of not
letting the perfect be your enemy and
just I I I think the imperfect so first
of all I think intent trumps all and I
think the second you really understand
what I just said you become far more you
know Lucid in your communication I'm
never scared to doing the wrong thing
tweeting the wrong thing promoting too
much because I'll apologize if I really
feel like I was wrong I actually
consulted one of my clients to do
something wrong on purpose so we could
say we're sorry because I think the
sorry is more valuable than the status
quo I mean it's crazy so the reason I'm
not crippled by Perfection or has to be
perfect or anything of that nature as a
matter of fact the one thing I've been
most scared about with this book coming
out is people critiquing what I'm
putting out content wise against your
own spe against my own spee because what
I'm doing is I'm still testing so I'm
still putting out links that autop
populate the pictures on Facebook
because I'm always testing and I'm like
oh man this is going to be tough to
explain because somebody's going to jump
in and be like Gary ve you just you know
wrote a book about you got to make a
picture why are you doing this and so
you know I'm never crippled by it cuz
intent matters because when I reply to
that person say listen I'm still testing
Baseline cuz Facebook's always changing
they're like oh there's like more value
for me to continue the smarts than me
being crippled by doing the wrong thing
so I think it's quite simple I think
that if you're willing to respect your
your your haters or the people that
don't agree or the people that are upset
with your last meal as long as you're
willing to respect them and have true
dialogue you can't lose unfortunately
some of us don't start out having a lot
of money yep and I actually I have a
website that I created that on Facebook
it went viral in 2010 has about 300,000
people on there it's great the thing is
that as you know I started working on
monetizing it and all this and then
timeline came along right and then they
started trying to charge for views I
used to get automatically 160,000 people
would see everything I did and now now
sometimes there's a post that I will do
and I'm I I've worked to be good at this
where 2,000 people will see it out of
300,000 people and it doesn't even make
sense when it says on the bottom and it
makes it very frustrating because as I'm
trying to build this and I'm trying to
grow it I'm right now the poorest person
to be featured in Forbes twice last year
yep so I really you know by the way you
need to wear that t-shirt make that
t-shirt wear that T-shirt and make that
T-shirt and wear that my friends
actually introduced me that way she's
the poorest person being let me explain
to yes a couple things number one what
we're getting a little technical now
Facebook doesn't let every person that
follows you see the picture post that
you're putting out there it's actually
the best thing they did let me explain
why everybody wants to look at it as
like they're trying to get my money to
boost my posts which is true on the flip
side open rates on email in the last
eight years have gone from 37% to 12% on
email newsletters because marketers ruin
everything if Facebook allowed every
person that they follow their fan page
up and their friends to show up in their
feed they would have the problem that
Twitter has now and email has now which
is there's so much noise nobody's
consuming anything so what they're doing
whether they're doing it effectively for
your specific page or mine what they're
trying to do is use people's actions to
require what they show up in their feed
so that the product the only asset
Facebook has is the actual user and so
they're trying to make it best for them
and their belief and I believe that's to
be true is that we need to populate the
things that they believe algorithmically
are the most important thing where you
where you needed to make a move and
where you need to make a move now is and
what I did when I started seeing that
happening as well is you can never never
be behold to just one platform so when I
started seeing that same thing in 2012
I'm like wait a minute they're starting
to really play here and I get it I
really do I really do believe they're
doing the right thing I truly do I
started making all my pictures used my
Instagram account to start siphoning
people to Instagram I started putting my
Pinterest pins in there I started ask
you should do a post every week that
asks people to follow you on your other
platforms you need to spread it out so
you're not be now I mean there's a lot
of people I'm sorry I I got to go to the
gentleman you
gra books to give you your friends hey
Gary how's it going man good man how are
you good um so my name is Vincent and I
uh I run a company that's a two Choice
voting platform with photos videos music
and the question that I have for you
today is like we we get some traction
with like Millennial kids and we've
signed a boy band um and so like the
kids have taken over the platform and
are really using it and asking lots of
questions about the you know the the
band and stuff like that the question
that I have is like how how how do we
take a um how do we leverage the fans
that are like on about this particular
band and try to turn it into you know
them asking questions about the other
stuff that's happening on the site does
that make sense like yeah and I think
the answer is you don't you don't what
what you're trying to do is say oh we
have all these users that ask about this
boy band if we can get them to ask
questions about other things we'll have
a bigger Network right the problem is
the more you try to force them to do
something they don't want to do the less
likely they'll come back at all and so
what you need to do is create more
parallel Paths of interest and replicate
what happened with the boy band with a
chef with you know wine guy with an off
like you you can't take a group that's
interested in something and make them
interested in other subject matter
they're not yours to make interest
they're borrowing you got it they're not
yours I I love when all my startups
think that they're their users they're
not their users their your product is
Theirs to borrow and so you have to
respect them and so what you're doing is
such a classic mistake in mentality of
okay we've got this now let's take these
people and make it good for us by making
them do other things instead of making
what they're there for even better for
them so they stay longer so we've got to
end now the book is so concise so clear
and so specific on what each of us can
do in so many different ways um it's
infrequent that I would say this but in
these kind of an events I I hope that 90
we get 90% sales here and the only
reason you don't is because somebody
can't afford it and then you're going to
get somebody else to do it for you so go
get this book Thank you guys